yo wats up guys busty here and all ran
welcome back to the fifth year fifth
episode of my minecraft hair abrin
Survival Series and what's sad now is we
have this new brand new 1.5 updates so
beautiful accepts tamad doesn't work
alright so i have been using this mod
and actually i was tripping for some
diamonds and i found some so we're gonna
go pick those up and now we will
probably be a few episodes without what
the heck is it with my skin my skin look
my skin is normal a white pickup this uh
so yeah and the mod is not I sorry
that's hard time twist the mod isn't
updated so we're gonna have to go
without the threat of hair around for a
few episodes which I think you can all
deal with but you can see here I got
some diamonds I've been a strip mining i
got i found a bunch of resources and I
sermon for diamonds so on a found them I
was one bunch more iron and I told radio
go ahead this way I found some more iron
and gold and all that and this stuff is
near some lava so we got to be careful I
think we're safe for the air safety pick
up that one all right now I don't think
this resin is going to be safe but I
really don't need it so I'll risk it
I'll risk it and place place place
alright now we're going to want to get
these diamonds back to home base since
the first diamonds of this series now
for this Sears has been gone well so I
will continue to do it as long as you
guys can continue to like it and when
you guys so like when you guys stopped
like now i will start doing it because
why would I do something like and yeah
that's basically it
however news are when the title update 9
comes out for the Xbox which will be the
equivalent to stamina I don't know what
it's going to add the end in in Xbox
minecraft this is the way out I will be
starting a survival series on that I
will also be doing video just about the
end and then I'm going to start my
survival series so if you guys like my
xbox then be sure to get ready for that
stat series since this here just going
to be cool like I've been wanting to
xbox one for a while but I didn't really
know when to start so this is a great
opportunity to start hook yeah I made it
sorry just collecting some materials
actually all I also found a dungeon
that's what we're going to do i found a
zombie dungeon so that's the second
dungeon we found and i have not
neutralized it so that will be the goal
of the first part of today's mission and
wow I never realized how big the
staircase was well i'm going to my
inventory but i can't all right we got a
budget emeralds good thing i set up shop
in a extreme Hills biomes and then we
can get to all of the emeralds and once
I find a village will be able to get all
the goodies last it would rain lag take
down my frame rates I'm still getting
like pretty good for a minute like it's
not like laggy so that's why I'm so I'm
actually I'm running with no smooth
lighting though because i'm not i don't
have Optifine on my computer is kind of
old but yeah octave i'm actually
probably they update that really fast
and that it's kind of like a if you
don't have to find is it's kind of just
to make the love lip sound its to make
better frames more frames so i will have
that once a lot of soon lose seven da
minge noise put that in the good section
of the the chest be of like this bottom
layers old goods all right now emerald
okay we got enough torches you got a
weapon
we can probably makes more iron armor
since I lost my cap boop boop boop boop
boop boop boop let's make some make some
shoes I don't want any leggings okay
okay i can do it out of them leggings
we're gonna want another pic we're gonna
want to equip this sauciness and put
away some of this redstone some of this
wood right there and some of the coal I
think we're good alright we want this
next to this yeah all right let's go get
that dungeon son hope I can remember
where it is so yeah I'm Irish all subs
me letting off wait sprint and I do I'm
gonna probably had stairs here because
you can now sprint up and down stairs in
1.5 02 so that'll be good I think it's
this way I don't know which one it's
down this way oh hmm think it might
Rosen incorrectly hmm I chosen correctly
back to where we came saw hey hook I can
just sort of going all the way back in
this tunnel across there we go this
better be the right way it's not then I
don't know where it is I think it is I
think it is yeah I found a few dungeons
yes yes it is done we are let's eat and
I put it towards there so it might be
parsonage all creeper it's a zombie
dungeon creeper well now they can spawn
for sure what but no no come on come on
nothing or not Oh what's up what that no
oh my gosh okay well you're not fighting
the zombies okay back and back up back
up what the health of dreary really it's
like okay I'm going to go I'm gonna go
check
got a zombie dungeon okay two creepers
just show up freaking heck okay zombies
are definitely spawning crap crap oh
crap they're all smart now too we can
smack him down enough go go go ah yeah
yeah like I think we neutralize it
alright kill you check these chests okay
we got some of thorns and i really like
thorns looks like good but I don't
really care for fire aspect and blast
protection none of these are that good
but I got some saddle so I can get that
achievement providing a pickoff clear
since I had not gotten doc and it also
goes into a bigger cavern awesome get
some gold all zombie and all gold armor
bro bro that's enchanted to hold of them
snap you out killed zombie get killed oh
that's a yeah give me that just played
oh it's basically dead whatever i guess
i'm sitting in there so we can that's
good block block block I hear some more
love we were on diamond hunting levels
so there's a little lava okay let's pick
up all this iron just scheppach
adventure yeah now we don't have to
worry about harebrained hair brawn I
still don't know like that like you guys
you you guys have even told me in the
comments like which one it is and I'm
just like I don't know I'm sure they bad
this all right I just I like picking up
all the koi see so I never ever ever
ever ever have to be like oh I need to
go mug cool I just want to be able to
have it man I hear all that law Boylan
bubblin little eerie noises let's play
some torch there just for safety
precautions safety precautions I'll get
all the Gold's all the Gold's basically
like the one thing the good gold is for
is uh getting them apples demopolis all
right let's black all this water because
it's going to be annoying as heck now
here's some more ambitious oh hello
zombie you got the higher ground that we
still win this battle let me go now
peaceful music yeah makes sense
minecraft I see a light source of love
here all been mine shaft yes yes yes I
got you stuck and creeper stuck oh my
gosh I found abandoned mineshaft like a
partial hello law Cooper okay I can walk
cobweb back off I'm gonna need a
probably craft new sword have any iron
on me oh no go away go away go away go
on no no no okay we're safe I do not
want to die with 26 levels on me that
would suck I don't I have a VI pieces of
iron so that's good break these have
another pic right yes I do we're good
all we're finding all the Lutz torch wat
de though some light and fails
why not come and visit on ha Aaron you
know even in the game anymore you're
less in the game I should say because
years always the game the mod just make
some more prevalent he's still trolling
us with them signs silly hair
ah ok so let's check out chest pump mall
is open for melon seeds what you might
need to start rationing out which goods
we want in which ones we don't want I
want some of this since this is an easy
way to get strained I know it's breaking
my sword but my sword can handle it but
that I just mean I'm going to make a new
sword soon hear it in case fighters and
getting all these rails on to make them
later I light up everything oh this is
this was an awesome find cheers bro and
I'm just like oh I'll just shut off all
the water lo and behold we got ourselves
and banded mineshaft this is a double
pocket iron I really don't need pumpkin
seeds so that could be a thing I could
dump and all the cobble I have all right
this is still part of the mine shaft
where that is at least all the these
freaking buggers can kill you so good
they are cave spiders they can like get
they poison you all you better watch
yourself so you want to get a torch
right there I'll back off now now
poisoning for you nope was in a few
where's the spawner oh there it's right
there what the heck is a little [ __ ]
oh no no no no no back up back if I come
back up eat eat I need to regenerate any
genetic no no no regenerates are
regenerating or generates regenerate
okay we're good I'm going to wait a
little bit just because I don't want
those stupid buggers to get me Booker's
why am I seeing buggers what the heck
okay swords almost broken so don't want
to be freaking without a sword mid-fight
stick 76 out how many sticks come on bro
get these sticks in here get the gadget
let me pick it up lock it up okay
glitching out stick
sort there we go okay I don't need you
and you and probably pick him up
afterwards but why can I hit him I guess
he's actually right start there oh there
doesn't sort the meantime I'll break
this so i can know all back not not not
not screw you crap live i just want to
place torch torch that might prevent
from spawning oh come on stop it stop it
stop it stop it there we go i am playing
on hard so poison can kill me I like it
what i thought id freaking stopped you
from spawning ok no no no come on please
tonight please no I please no please
don't no please don't die don't die
don't die no no no no no no no no no no
no no ok can't can we can kill me ok ok
I'm never generate no of my health screw
this oh my gosh hold up quick check okay
all right there about that 15-minute
mark saw in the video hot in this little
hole I hope you guys all enjoyed this
next video I'll return I don't get those
spiders if you got all the way here to
the end please I would really appreciate
a like a comment and if you're new
subscribe if you really enjoyed it
favourite it and share it to other
people so it gets my videos more known
but my guys manage prestige and I will
see you all later